hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start
warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2021 american
dark fantasy movie called night books
the movie begins with a boy who lives in
a spooky apartment called alex he loves
to write scary stories and collect them
in a series of books he called night
books one night alex is furious and
swears to his mom that he will never
write another story again he grabs all
his night books and runs away from his
apartment while his parents are having
arguments privately he intends to burn
all his riding collections thus he
descends to the lower floor where the
furnace room is located unfortunately
the elevator stops on the wrong floor
and alex begins to explore the corridor
he is lured to enter an apartment room
where he accidentally eats a pumpkin pie
and passes out while the apartment's
door suddenly shuts by itself
alex awakens and finds himself trapped
in a magical apartment he tries to jump
out of the window but is brought back to
the magical room
suddenly he is haunted by a mysterious
creature who turns out to be a beautiful
witch named natasha claiming herself to
be the owner of the apartment
she explains that the apartment lures
children and they will be killed if they
cannot deliver unique value to the witch
alex claims that his specialty is to
write scary stories he ensures natasha
that his stories are really good and in
order to survive he must tell a scary
story every single night to her while
sleeping alex is suddenly being attacked
by natasha's pet lenora who has the
ability to be invisible
the kitty knocks him out of his room and
he starts exploring the apartment
he discovers that the tv that lured him
previously has gone and the door has
also disappeared alex then meets another
witch's prisoner yasmin whose job is to
be a housekeeper while cleaning the mess
caused by lenore she explains that the
apartment travels all over the world
finding kids to be lured in which allows
the witch to travel to anywhere she
wants yasmin then brings alex to the
witch's enormous library where she keeps
the scary story books from all around
the world
she explains that every book in the
library has already been read even
though alex has stopped writing scary
stories yasmine forces him to do so if
he wants to survive
while attempting to escape alex
discovers another exit door that natasha
uses to come in which connects the
apartment to the outside world he runs
towards the door but it suddenly
disappears
he is spotted by the witch who warns him
that there is no escape
at night alex begins to tell his first
story before he starts natasha sprays
herself with a blue mist that alex
believes keeps her young the apartment
suddenly starts shaking and she orders
alex to read his story immediately the
story's title is the playground it is
about a boy who arrives at a haunted
playground to find a girl he likes jenny
the happy ending of the story causes the
room to start shaking again and makes
natasha furious alex tries to improvise
the story until the room stops shaking
she warns alex to never tell a happy
ending story again because it is
dangerous the next day alex starts
working on his new scary story again he
explores the library and ascends to the
higher level of the library
while reading through the library's old
books for inspiration he accidentally
spots handwritten messages in the
frankenstein book
he notices that it is a diary from the
other kidnapped girl and reveals that
there were other kids in the apartment
suddenly yasmin comes in and reminds
that dinner will be ready in an hour
causing alex to stop exploring the diary
as usual alex continues telling scary
stories to natasha every night for
several days and she keeps interrupting
him when she is unimpressed with the
storyline she states that every good
story hints at truth and urges him to
get the facts straight while creating or
telling a story
alex resumes to explore every book in
the library to find other handwritten
message until he discovers a book with a
unicorn necklace drawing and other
messages in it since then he gives a
nickname to the writer unicorn girl
in the book the unicorn girl reveals
that she had found the way to escape
which gives alex hope
yasmin suddenly comes in and introduces
alex to natasha's night nursery where
the magical plans are stored she asks
alex to help her to destroy the shredder
eggs because they can destroy the whole
nursery if they hatch
yasmin slips from the ladder and drops
the egg alex manages to catch the
falling egg but it hatches and starts
cutting down the other shredder eggs
causing them to start hatching as well
they are able to destroy the eggs but
the treasure begins wreaking havoc in
the nursery and lenore comes to help the
kids
lenora is trapped and the shredder is
coming after him but luckily alex
manages to eliminate it with a hoe and
rescues the kitty
unfortunately there is still one
shredder egg unnoticed and starts
hatching natasha is enraged and punishes
the kids with her magic however she
decides not to kill them because she
needs them to clean up the mess
at night alex is attacked by a shredder
and manages to kill it however before it
attacked alex it destroyed all the night
books inside alex's bag
the next day alex is frustrated and out
of ideas to write a new scary story
turns out that yasmin is expert in herbs
and potions as she brings a concoction
to cure alex's and lenore's wounds
because the night books were destroyed
alex states that there is no other way
but to run away yasmine explains that
there are two doors in the apartment the
front door where he came in and the back
door which links to the outside world
she also adds that natasha keeps her
door's keys and tells him to forget
about the escape plan
yasmin shows alex the figurines of
previously trapped kids who are yasmin's
friends and tells him that natasha will
curse him into it if he disobeys
alex then realizes that every figurine
wears a certain stuff such as watches
and earrings but none of them wears a
unicorn necklace
he deduces that the unicorn girl must
successfully have managed to escape
after realizing that there is a way out
the peers search through old books to
find other unicorn girls notes and
discover a sleeping potion in the
original hands and gretel book
however the potion smells awful and they
need to find the missing ingredient
before giving it to the witch in order
to steal the keys alex plans to trick
natasha into giving them the final
ingredient of the sleeping potion by
purposely telling a fake story because
natasha likes stories to be truthful
at night alex tells her a story about a
sorcerer who uses a sleeping potion on a
beast but he keeps using the incorrect
ingredient to hide the smell pineweed
long story short and as expected natasha
explains that bindweed is used to keep
liquid from separating and leaks that
cineroot is the correct ingredient to
hide smells mission successful
the bear gather the ingredients and
start making the sleeping potion
alex attempts to pour the potion into
the lemonade but fails as the color
turns green so they cancel the plan
tonight alex is unprepared and fails to
deliver the scary story which makes
natasha very angry and the kids beg for
forgiveness when she is about to cast
his spell she suddenly passes out it
turns out that lenore has slipped the
potion into her perfume which he used
previously before hearing the story alex
realizes that lenore is also a prisoner
the kids steal the keys and has key
through the back door soon they realize
that the woods are just another section
within the apartment an evil unicorn
appears and they are chased by it the
pair eventually arrive at a cottage from
hansel and gretel's book which is made
of candy they get into the cottage and
jasmine is affected by the magic causing
her to start eating the candy and
disappear
alex reaches the weird basement where he
is confronted by natasha who has
captured lenore and yasmin natasha
reveals that the mysterious figure is
the original witch whose body is used to
harvest the mist it turns out that the
blue mist doesn't keep her young but it
is what gives her magical powers natasha
was once trapped in there and become the
original witch's favorite so she didn't
eat her
she managed to escape with the sleeping
potion but her parents left him she also
reveals that the shaking in the
apartment was caused by the original
witch because she demands a scary story
that will keep her asleep
the basement starts shaking and natasha
forces alex to tell her why he intended
to burn the night books earlier he
explains how everyone at school made fun
of him for his hobby of writing horror
stories one day his only friend josh
chose to come to other friends gaming
party instead of his birthday party and
no one showed up at his birthday party
he was embarrassed and decided to burn
the night books alex then purposely
gives the story a happy ending though as
he says being captured was the best
thing to happen to him because he met
friends who love him for who he is
causing the original witch to wake up
natasha fights the witch while the kids
are escaping from the basement
unfortunately she lost the battle and
gets crushed by the debris yasmine uses
the stolen perfume bottle and reveals
the front door
they finally reach the elevator and
descend to the furnace room but the
witch follows them the witch manages to
capture yasmin but alex uses a scary
story to lure her and throw a blank to
the boiler as bait
the witch goes after the book and they
shove her into the boiler finally
killing her
after that alex returns home and yasmin
is reunited with her parents after 3
years he even starts writing again and
keeps in touch with yasmin who gives him
a new notebook while also looking after
lenore at the end of the movie the
figurines begin to break free and it is
shown that natasha survives from the
debris
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching